the covet threat is looming large over
the tokyo olympics where competition has
already begun
even before the opening ceremony this
friday this morning the u.s women's
soccer team had a disappointing start in
their quest for olympic gold
losing to sweden in their first game but
that isn't the end of their run they
play against saturday
and in softball the u.s women's team
beat
italy jamie yukis has just landed in
tokyo to cover the games
all right i'm at the pre-approved
testing site for covid
after two required cova tests in los
angeles
i was off on my 5500 mile trip to tokyo
you have to stay at your hotel for 14
days the only places you're allowed to
go
are workspaces pre-approved venues or
the convenience store around the corner
the protocols are just as strict for
olympic athletes
although athletes are not required to be
vaccinated the safety protocols are
strict and involve
rigorous testing for anyone connected to
the games
spectators have been barred from most
events any athlete who has come in close
contact with someone testing positive
must test daily and quarantine in a
single dorm room
including for meals with the opening
ceremony only two days away
uncertainty surrounding this year's
games continues
the ceo of tokyo 2020 said officials
will continue to monitor the situation
as it unfolds
usa today sports columnist nancy armour
when you hear that there could be a last
minute cancellation
no that's not going to happen that train
left the station a long
long time ago these games are happening
and yet the number of positive cases
continues to rise more than 70 people
from
athletes to staff have been infected
with the virus nba star bradley beal was
forced to miss the olympics
after being placed in health and safety
protocols fellow usa basketball star
katie lou samuelson tested positive
before leaving the u.s
tennis star coco gough and gymnast cara
acre also returned positive tests
aker traveled and trained with usa
gymnastics in japan
now you know every morning i'm checking
social media to see if the the women
have posted photos of them at training
i'm checking with usa gymnastics and the
usopc to see
did everybody test negative again today
there is no magic shield around you just
because you are vaccinated
despite health and safety concerns the
head of the world health organization
called the games today a celebration of
hope vlad
celebration for sure but 70 people is
not a small number jamie to be continued
thank you very much